would rather do what you want to do to
please the Democratic party in Chicago
as you know there's crazy crime now
they've got they Sanctuary CI so they've
got all the problem with the immigrants
and everything else the illegal
immigrants I should say the illegal
aliens I should say uh anyway uh some
black people in Chicago and black people
are thought of as oppressed in America
so you have to believe them when they
say something uh they're sort of pissed
that the migrants are getting all the
services and they're thinking about
leaving the Democrats here's check just
check this out we're here to say to
Black alen who are elected by the black
citizens of Chicago that we are fed up
with you not hearing our stress and our
demands but rather do what you want to
do to please the Democratic party we are
fed up with you for not taking the lead
to stop the buses we are fed up with you
for not demanding of Brandon Johnson to
remove illegal immigrants from our
community and we're also here to say we
are we are
denouncing uh Alderman William Hall and
lont Robinson for going to the border to
look into the eyes of illegal immigrants
but has failed to look into the eyes of
homeless black men women and children
and other citizens of Chicago we have
veterans who have served this country
who are hom have you looked into their
eyes if this mass increases immigration
continues all wages and employment for
black workers and potential workers will
fall our position is that we will not
quietly sit by and allow poor destitute
people from around the world come to
Chicago and be dumped into poor
destitute communities in the city of
Chicago to please the political agenda
of black Alderman the uh the mayor of
the city of Chicago and the governor of
the state of Illinois as well as the
President of the United States reach
sister yeah everything she said there is
true they have had it they have had
Decades of democrat rule Democrats have
destroyed their city with crime and
shootings and everything else in the
last few years Democrats have destroyed
their city with uh the sanctuary city
concept which of course just allows
illegals to come in and get services and
there aren't unlimited Services much
like there's not unlimited amounts of
anything so then you have to start
taking away from the other people who
want those Services I also have to say I
kind of dig a woman in a full denim
outfit seems like a very simple thing to
put on you know I me I got to button
this and this and this the whole thing
just getting like a big denim thing that
seems kind of
uh but of course she's right and
Democrats you're going to have to choose
uh who do you like more black people or
illegals and I know that's going to be a
tough one for you cuz you also want the
illegals to vote which is why you don't
want voter ID but you're going to have
to work that one out uh here's just a
couple images of what's happening on the
streets of Chicago right in the area
that that woman was talking about this
is right next door by the way to the
local police department uh sent in
pictures from makeshift migrant camps
near the 17th District on Leland between
Harding and psaki these are the
conditions uh these are conditions that
are neither conducive for local
residents nor migrants indeed it's not
conducive to anything good for anybody
but that is where we are
at